this is the Wolverine movie where he
wakes up and the most yeah he falls he
moves to sleep an awful lot in this
proofing is like this is the inception
of Wolverine movies because at the very
beginning it's like a dream sequence
followed by waking up that example is
followed by waking up at the other
direction in the real world then he
keeps getting like knocked unconscious
yeah did it go ahead and you don't get
poisoned go to sleep he's evening what
Raiden really gets his rest in this game
and then the one night he says he's not
gonna sleep at all you fell asleep like
that second he said it does because he's
in bed hey bub
I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry welcome
two reasons to see will we give you
reasons to see and not to see the
Wolverine
so let's hang out
reason to see number one Hugh Jackman
no it's me Hugh Jackman as usual Vereen
you yeah thank God he's in the role yeah
you know I don't think anybody else
could play him at this point like he's
play what like five times now maybe
Matthew McConaughey you gotta let me go
after magneto but no your Jackman
[ __ ] Rock City diamond it's great
because it feels so fresh well doesn't
that thing about any of these x-men
movies is like no matter how bad a
couple of them have been Hugh Jackman
always does a really good job
always really good you know what's cool
about him is he's so much darker in this
one you feel more of a violent kind of
guy and more of a mess I know he's got a
little bit of Mel Gibson in him if you
know what I mean yeah yeah he's not
racist no no he likes Japanese people oh
that's great
but he keeps really really abusing his
wife yeah he keeps killing machine he's
got the charm he's got the charisma man
said it before I'll say it again gonna
suck his dick Hugh Jackman does such a
good job especially in this movie
because there's always humor but it's
like in this movie I really got the
sense that he had a great balance for
the dark stuff and the dramatic stuff
and then some of the more humorous like
a 2d thing he brings them to life again
it's like he he can just step into this
role like it's no [ __ ] big deal it's
nice to have a good actor who's super
committed yeah being a superhero is
gonna play him like 18 times there yeah
yeah no matter how old the guy gets I
think he's gonna be able to pull this
off yeah cuz he has worked out
incredibly he is super buff in this film
it's in he's like I'm a 6000 calorie
diet or something like that
my friend was telling you about that
apparently he has to like wake up in the
middle of the night and eat whole
chickens it paid off he has his shirt
off plenty of times you know movie or or
he's just wearing a wife-beater and
that's it
yeah you know my personal opinion I
think this is the best Wolverine
performance we've gotten so far
no but it's it's the best sex my movie
that I think for sure it's the best
Wolverine performance it's like the
standalone movie we've been waiting for
in so many ways it was cool the centers
in Japan
it was kind of like Japan stories I
don't need to comic so I didn't really
know but then I watched it and I was
like this makes perfect sense of the
identification of samurai and warrior
you know dying by honor all these things
I don't like does that's yes that's
Wolverine right there that we've been
waiting for because all these movies
will ready just been lost this time we
get to see like you said a lot of
different sides you know the justice
side and also the lost sides the burdens
you know it's the first time you really
feel like you're learning his identity
internally what's the most interesting
stuff to is that stuff when they were
making over in human like the
vulnerability of it was so effective
like you like the way there's that too
oh definitely yeah there's more danger
but I didn't and everything you you care
more for this guy he's more identifiable
in this movie is it's a great [ __ ]
performance like he makes this film like
he does even if the bill somehow it
would be awesome wait a minute so yeah
I'd even go so far as to say that even
if you don't feel the film is great it's
like you have to give Hugh Jackman a
separate grade reason to see number two
we're gonna bring that back yeah
everything are going to shadow is
putting three fingers up or or if you
were at schools like pencils oh yeah you
put the pennies a little bit sold and
then wanted them on your left hand would
always be crooked now I'm gonna bring
that [ __ ] back cuz right when I got in
the car look and I have felt it you felt
that the action in this is cool for the
first timing since like x-men 2 he's
like really [ __ ] up people in this
movie you know is you I really get to
say yeah you don't see up a lot but you
really do get this as that he is tearing
dudes apart I liked it because it was a
combination of action and violence it
wasn't like just some action flick you
know like there was drama behind the
violence there was you know it fit into
the story
yeah the giant samurai guy I don't know
if it's in the Congress or not I thought
was cool look at and that bullet train
fight I had to take some bullet train
fight that was amazing that was pretty
Sweeting over the top but for some
reason that fight hinged to me I don't
know why on one detail because they were
doing the hop thing yeah and I was like
this is getting a little ridiculous and
then he did the fake yeah
something gets hit by anything I was
like yes this is awesome that one moment
was pushed me over that was incredible
great effects - I thought it was gonna
suck when I saw the Train well because
that's that's the thing that happen
again in x-men origins and not to keep
comparing it but really yeah like
plasticy and that was like great in this
movie yeah they do I was like good
because they show a lot of the pan with
a bone claws as well and it all looks
good it all it all looks [ __ ] great
there's not a ton of action in this
movie but every action scene has its own
flavor I will say like a few times
during the action scenes I would get
chills chills would come on my body cuz
I was like that like whoa this is cool
the first fight scene at the funeral I
got chills I was like this is really
good stuff and the archer dude oh [ __ ]
like that was awesome well that's it
I've heard some people complain about
this movie in terms of the editing and
the fight photography specifically
basically saying like ah you know James
mango really keeps that camera shakiest
oh but this was a movie to where I sort
of noticed partway through the fights I
was like for me it was on the borderline
of being chaotic because the camera is
shaky and there's lots of fast cutting
but for some reason it was just enough
that I got every shot and I wasn't lost
so good on them for that yeah I was able
to keep up with everything I saw I did
there is chaotic have you seen the
Bourne movies geez oh that's chaotic
pleasin to see number 3 yukiho
I'm glad Ken joke hey Stowe Yukio the
Asian well there's a lot of Asian be
sure so most of the cab
you Jack mint and and and Viper like the
two white people Yukio once all this
character and the trailer I was like am
I gonna be impressed with this character
I asked myself that question I didn't I
thought she looked cool oh you did I
wasn't I was like I thought she had a
weird face is she so she'd I mean she
has a very I got big forehead and it was
like it goes in well she's got that kind
of like not beat shaved of it like that
heart-shaped like she let happy Tim
Burton character yeah you nailed it cuz
I thought that movie
like she doesn't have one of those like
heart-shaped faces and yes you should be
in you know I mean you know watch what
the [ __ ] wrong with her oh yeah but
she and I'm having a castor just on that
level because she's not like the super
attractive she's not texting yeah like
there was something endearing about her
to look at but she does have a very
strange look and I appreciated that they
gave a cool part to something with the
strange look yeah and they made her
really cool and she was essential to the
story and I would love to see her in and
another one of these movies I thought
she was a great person to play off
Wolverine x-men origins Yukio let's do
this let's do this she can she can tell
when people are gonna go join the x-men
first hey do this reason to see number
four writing and directing here we go
here we go James mingled man I I liked
her movies a lot even night and day
everyone hates on that but I really
enjoyed that hell out of that film I
haven't seen it okay when I heard uh
Darren Aronofsky dropped out of this I
was like that sucks well then again I
was like that so that would probably the
most depressing Wolverine movie ever
made it would be cool that it would be
dark it would be dark behind me a little
bit notic to you would be a Hollywood
probably sort somehow light untangle
himself by becoming obsessed with
mortality
I think the holiday I think those dream
sequences orgy would have been a lot
more violent but but ya know I'm with
you there I heard well you didn't make a
point but yeah James Mangold directed
this movie don't know who wrote it but I
really enjoyed the storytelling of this
movie it felt did it feel like an
excellent movie it was just a standalone
film and that's how it felt fresh they
really had to just tell a good Wolverine
story you know like you said earlier
putting him in Japan and they really
capture the spirit of what they were
going for here I really felt it and
David mango pull off the action well and
he yeah you he knew had it didn't have
like out of place humor either I think
it was it all fit perfectly and at the
same time too it's not like I mean it
takes place in a world that has mutants
but it doesn't feel like this is a
mutant world so then yeah focuses more
time
yeah I wouldn't use the word subtle to
describe this movie but it's definitely
lot more came down than your average
superhero film yet in my opinion
fantastic superhero film you really get
to know wolverine like you they actually
managed to pull off this Wolverine movie
where you're usually dealing with an
immortal and in this case it's like
there's a real sense of danger going on
in this film yeah well that's a nice
twist and I think you hit the nail on
the head before when you you sort of
touch them that idea that you can see
how this fits into the x-men universe
but it doesn't feel like an x-men movie
and that is cool because it makes it
feel more worthwhile I know that they
took some inspiration from from at least
one sort of famous Wolverines story that
does take place in Japan and I thought
you know all those themes really cool to
explore any I'm making it mortal does
give a different edge because how would
Wolverine maneuver in this situation you
see physicality struggles this time as
well not just this internal struggle so
it amplifies the whole experience with
it in this film is mainly a drama it's
not bombarded with action yeah it's it
doesn't feel like a big comic book
tentpole movie yeah exactly and it's
just [ __ ] cool yeah I thought oh is
this really rad sandwich
I think it's paced well and the action
yell looks good and the dramatic moments
work and the humors right the only
complaint I have about the writing is
that you know some of the dialogue was a
little wooden to me when they get really
exposition II but that's really only the
only complaint I had about the writing I
like what they did with the story and
the characters and stuff like that it's
important I just love the overall tone
to just the mood of it I like the
character art they set up a Wolverine to
of this guy who just takes himself funny
you know like you really get the sense
that this guy does want to die the story
really is about him finding himself you
know all these other excellent movies he
just lost and like who the [ __ ] am I and
then I move origins Wolverine it's like
okay here's [ __ ] that happened but he's
gonna forget all of it it's so well
thing is in the x-men movies you know
you kind of see him rise to the occasion
because there's a greater good and it's
cool to go off and explore him on his
own because then you can have that sort
of like self-hatred struggle and the
struggle of do I want to keep living or
not it manages to take a character that
comes from such a science fiction type
of universe tame it down alex is such a
human war
and make it a really good movie where
you're not going I want to see all the
other mutants what's going on no reason
to see number five better than x-men
origins Wolverine yeah but what isn't
these days a lot of people that I know
personally said do I really want to
watch this film cuz x-men origins
Wolverine sucked they totally redeem
themselves in this movie yeah yeah well
because that's the bummer is that x-men
origins Wolverine came out at a time
where we were like really getting in the
swing of these heavier superhero movies
with character bits and all that stuff
so we're like Wolverine movie all we're
gonna explore this character and then
that whole movie is nothing but him
going like no just showing events you're
not really exploring the character yeah
I was like I thought the claws were
supposed to be a stigma and here you are
like check it out guys it was anytime I
get you know it's just a sequence of
events that's all it is
even if you hate it it's still a step up
from that one oh yeah it's like you
don't think about origins Wolverine when
you're watching this move now it's like
you're not going you know if you're
drinking to remember yeah you're really
just enjoying the hell out of this film
and the tones are different again to
this movie just has much more life to it
you know it's there's a real spirit
about it there's a real energy got this
movie unlike origins Wolverine which got
me worried for the franchise this movie
literally had me so excited to see
another like x-men film like yeah that
got me pumped I was like yes this is
this is it essentially that post-credits
Team Holy Mother of God yes yes that's
read the Virgin Mary came james mangold
and said I'm gonna top your movie off so
well this was one of the best
post-credits things i've ever seen and
just in case you didn't know the virgin
mary is really into comics yeah I had
never been this excited for an x-men
movie before because we got x-men first
class and then we got a good Wolverine
standalone movie yeah and now it's like
then we have the x-men movies and now
we're just gonna
threw [ __ ] together and it's so cool it
is the most out like one of the most
awesome postcard stings because it's
like a family reunion to like we've been
waiting forever for these guys to come
back and it's like McQuillen and then
you know you're like that's rad and then
you know penny Stewart shows up and
you're like oh like everyone stands up
and freaks out yeah it's interesting
because it's like the x-men universe in
its way is its own Marvel Universe yeah
you know what I mean like 20th Century
Fox they don't need the Marvel movies
that are happening because they got the
x-men universe where they have their own
Marvel Studios than is called x-men yeah
cuz they expand this is full of
superheroes
yeah and full of villains and there's
the takes place in universes and stuff
they got their own thing going on it's
kind of cool to see like Marvel has you
know all these individual stories that
come together but then they got this one
story that's like the ultimate of
ultimate superpower stories and that's
the x-men of the world reason to see
number 6 production design I loved
studying it in Japan man that was it was
a beautiful look at sets four great all
the houses that were built the it's more
like a lot of the good lot of the fights
took place fantastic absolutely amazing
look at get this sort of big city sort
of Tokyo style vibe and then you also
get the more rural you know country
areas which is a cool just range of
aesthetics plus you know the movie
starts out during world war two so
there's a lot on you know different
timelines and places so it's there's a
lot of really cool stuff to look at and
the designs are all really cool
definitely definitely and this is the
category that most people look forward
to the production design line I want to
see that movie because it looks like
that
don't production anything yeah like
columns are awesome did you see the way
those buildings reasons not to see Viper
it didn't not like this actress she I
thought she thought she was in a
different movie I can see how you would
think that like I wasn't so much
bothered by the actress I think as much
as I was kind of bothered by the
character the character ball do you MA
right
the actors really but she seems so
cartoony I mean she was a little bit of
a mustache yeah it seemed like why are
you trying to chain up the cedar in here
like it doesn't fit in this yeah she
doesn't like the first time she walks by
it's like it's very obvious you're evil
yeah like are you even trying to hide
this from the guy you're nursing right
now like I say every line with a smile
on my face cuz I am evil yeah and I like
being yeah that is true like the first
scene she comes through you're like is
she evil and then the next time you see
her when she's in that crowd with the
phone you're like you're definitely yeah
I think she starts talking in the scene
with the archery guy and I'm like what
is up with your acting god it pulled me
out of the movie that was the one moment
bra that one moment she started speaking
I was like ah this is the first time I'm
what not liking something yeah yeah I
don't necessarily think she did a bad
acting job but she is acting for a
different film of definitely and I
didn't quite get the character fully it
seemed like she had like purpose and
they really set it up like she has
purpose she knew we didn't know yeah we
just never really get to know what the
purpose is yeah you've got some evil
idea I'm not sure what it is yeah I
don't get why you're running all this
[ __ ] what is in this for you that was
one one thing about this movie that
wasn't I think flushed out well enough
was cuz he got a lot of villains in this
movie when you think about it the more
human villains are more fleshed out but
like you got like Viper in it who a lot
of people know of and it's like she's
she comes in and then this is kind of
just a strategy yeah I feel like she's
kind of in the plot too
she's kind of there to move the plot
along and then they were like this would
be a good opportunity to throw another
you know music yeah reason not to see
number two parts of the third act yeah
yeah when it becomes important
Wolverines like there's one claw you
haven't taken
and that would be very on the real Man
of Steel yeah you know like I really
loved this song but in the third act a
lot of people are like complaining about
it and I can kind of see why I could
actually really see why I I was I was
starting to get pulled out because I it
starts feeling rushed and then it's not
getting bombarded it's like well the
villains are just here right now and
yeah the third act of her people say
this and I think it is true the third
act is when it car kinda yeah kind of
shifts gears and it's like but now let's
be a superhero movie and now it's like
super sci-fi you know where it's like
yeah that's like when the action starts
happening it was like robots ooh whoa
yeah lot of info very fast all the
sudden this wouldn't get Bueller skin
off
I guess you're evil now I like what's
going on over the archer character too
like what why what what side is he on
yeah he goes from being like likable
helper to kind of still likable but in a
more conflicted way not helper yeah and
I felt like what they were going for was
a build-up because there's not a lot of
action so I felt like they were going
for a build up to have an awesome
action-packed finale but it didn't quite
have that effect it felt more like this
is you got a great drama going on with
some action now you're just like whoa is
too much yeah you get into the third act
and you're kind of sitting there going
this seems like the part where the test
audience was like there should be more
action yeah yeah still for what it is
and there's still things in the third
act that I really enjoy you can't deny
that there's some good action in the
third act it's not it's not like and I
like Man of Steel but it's not like Man
of Steel words like story story story
story story actually is a little bit
like let's put more action than we've
done already
yeah much faster you know and say yeah
it does kind of mess up the flow a bit
and Michelle brought this up to me why
did they just do like a bone marrow
transplant on the guy I'm Wolverine you
know couldn't they have just yeah that
seemed like they were mr. adamantine
yeah somebody could have been like hey
dude I know you went through all this
let's at least fix you up then you have
to like drill and so that was actually I
that was one of those
like that it was I had phantom pain in
between my knuckles because I was like
that looks like it hurts
no no what was that and I also had the
feeling of you could have just done like
a bone marrow drive I was thinking that
you didn't need to go through all of
that oh you mean what he's actually
trying to steal the yeah oh I bought why
you going so deep because it's like
because it's deep like I don't know kind
of thing that seems like you would have
to dig in deep to get the juicy
ex-missus wouldn't be smart just knock
them unconscious and then like billions
of dollars like it made sense of it at
the moment yeah but I was like but I
thought about it it wasn't you go
through he was killing two birds with
one stone he's like here's my crazy
strong in robot body and instead of
having to hop in after I get young again
I'm just gonna do it all together it was
kind of predictable to me when they
reveal that it was the old guy in the in
the suit I saw that coming
yeah it was like I bought that he died
at first I was like okay maybe that's
something Logan was gonna have to live
with and then as time went on and they
and there kept being like not much
attention to him and then talking about
him a lot of a thing he must know pretty
good Ryan
consensus despite a couple of things the
Wolverine is the reason movies are made
despite a couple things the Wolverine is
the reason movies are made yeah I really
dug this film it got me excited I
thought I loved that it was it's one of
my favorite superhero movies in general
because it's just about a individual
hero and they managed to make it feel
fresh as ever and it was added and it's
all blast I don't a serious film Gerry's
Gazette says there are a lot of reasons
to see The Wolverine especially because
it's better than x-men origins Wolverine
there are a lot of reasons to see the
Wolverine especially because it's much
better than x-men origins Wolverine yeah
man really good time with this movie and
it gave me sort of that stuff I wish
that origins had seen get a lot of
character exploration there's some cool
action you know I'm not in love with it
but I had
really good time and I'll watch it again
alright guys let's check it out a review
for the Wolverine thank you thank you
very much thank you for being here
why don't you go ahead you scroll back
comic box and tell us your x-men movies
in your favorite order not your accident
movies the x-men movies in your favorite
daughter and then once you get done with
that why don't you come on over here and
click this button to see more episodes
of reasons to see because you know
that's the next thing you want to do
yeah yeah yeah then when you're done
with that why don't you like decide to
yourself you want to permanently get
updated with us in every possible way
so like us on Facebook and then follow
us on Twitter last but not least once
you got comments and and reasons and
Twitter and Facebook you're gonna want
to get updated every time a new reviewer
video is out so subscribe this is a lot
of stuff raske yeah they are yeah yeah
it literally is a art v we want you to
do a lot of things and please do all of
them like us too that would be the sixth
request subscribe to our Pinterest sure
and our friends dirt donate money to us
yeah hey Kickstarter Ken yeah we use a
bigger Wolverine poster wait now take
two yeah we could use a bigger reasons
to see poster we could you know what
else would you do we did kick-started we
could make prized packages like you give
us $25 we'll give you 50 no that would
directly not work no no it's like you
give us $25 which is enough for two
movie tickets you get to tell us what
movies review who they'll be like you
know it's like you picked off a bug the
person movie okay yeah Kickstarter
campaign or IndieGoGo what you guys
might do that comment below
7th request Wow we are just high
maintenance
you